nous sommes au technopôle angus c'est
ici que l' agence de publicité lg2 élira
domicile dans un an
lg2 acquis l'endroit les campagnes des
producteurs de lait est en pleine
croissance et a besoin d' espace
l'entreprise quitte le boulevard
saint-laurent pour s'installer dans les
stands de montréal mais pourquoi l'est
on voulait pas avoir un site
on voulait avoir un feat et on le
trouvait dans l'ess est spécifiquement
chez angus parce que c'est une place ou
un autre façon on pouvait faire une
différence
on peut contribuer à revitaliser un
quartier lg2 le transporteur x t elle le
géant français d'articles de sports
décathlon
ce sont là quelques exemples de sociétés
qui ont décidé de miser sur ce secteur
de montréal
le résultat pour l'est est indéniable
quoi la chambre de commerce locale qui
vient de dévoiler ses grandes priorités
pour le secteur adopté l'expression à la
chambre de commerce de l'est ça se passe
dans l'est parce qu'on sent
effectivement qui a un boss selon le
promoteur du technopole qui a attiré lg2
ce n'est que le début
pense qu'il ya 15-20 ans d'efforts à
redonner une nouvelle image à l'aise
morial à enlever l'image traditionnelle
de la pétrochimie de l'industrie lourde
mais il ya d'autres raisons bien sûr
parmi elles des coûts de location dans
le secteur industriel qui sont en
moyenne 9 % moins chers que ceux du
centre ville ou de l'ouest de montréal
des terrains à des prix souvent plus
avantageux organes donc laval quand on
regarde le prix demandé aux pieds carrés
niveau de ventes
on dépasse le cadre manar du 100 $ le
pied carré donc dans l'est on est dans
le 80 dollars selon cette firme de
courtage les ce n'est pas le seul
secteur en croissance ce qui le
distingue des autres c'est le fait que
pendant une quinzaine d'années
c'était le calme plat maintenant les
grues sont visibles le couple et curieux
se segmenter qu'elle presque 50%
on parle de l'est dans le temps l'est
c'était vraiment le dernier des recours
pour continuer à prendre son essor l'est
de montréal devra impérativement se
doter d'un réseau de transport plus
adéquat et
retour des contaminés d'importantes
superficies encore inexploité pour les
rendre attrayantes pour les promoteurs
ici maxime bertrand radio canada morrell